wir kommen zum fragen warum du hast du
mal davon gehört
die roten sind auf jeden fall scheiß
fragen genau diese frage genau das
richtige übergeben und sie mal richtig
power also jetzt nicht mal zeit etwas
richtig ist zu lernen
ich weiß nicht welche [ __ ] diese
frage gestellt aber woher willst du
nicht wissen sie schon was richtiges
gelernt
schwule sau du hast nicht so richtig
gemacht
die schule sei ja wohl recht
die schule sei mit der frage ja
vielleicht auch noch nicht gemacht ich
will nicht sagen sonst was ist die frage
ist ja komisch was das ist ein richtiges
lernen also was die frage ich sehe diese
herstellung ja da hätte einfach fragen
können müsste ich meine ausbildung
machen will stehen gesagt mach ich nicht
lust die müssen ja provozieren dafür
sind die frage ist kein problem ich
bekomme ich hier noch lebend raus im
moment bist du noch nicht auf der
abschlussliste was am ende eine grüne
frage hier merkels adrenalin steigt der
blutdruck auch alles easy sie also weißt
du [ __ ] nicht so gemein natürlich
nächste alles von wem hast du dein
schauspieltalent keine ahnung also das
kann ich hier so nicht beantworten ich
weiß jetzt habe ich ja nur ob
schauspieler ist ja irgendwie talent
haben oder nicht ja dann für einige
gesagt dass ich auf ihrem talent haben
feierlich natürlich alter wenn es in dem
bereich auch mal vielleicht was geben
würde sich auf jeden fall begrüßen alles
fängt ja schon an bei wiederzusehen
geladen
spuren von james bond stil auf jeden
fall ich gucke viele filme also da habe
ich viele al pacino filme gucken oder
robert de niro sind auf jeden fall die
zum 1 also der tipp wenn man schaue ich
mir da werden wir viel von schauspieler
sehen will wenn der effekt filmen welche
jemals gesehen also al pacino stück alle
ich habe alle filme vor der filmfreak
okay ich guck alles auf einen liebesfilm
und so auch liebesfilm gilt also kannst
du schon wieder name grün
ich schnappe mir die roten auch eine
kleines jahre wieder wenn ich ja
beruhigt - du bist so vielseitig begabt
was können wir in zukunft von dir
erwarten also danke dir erstmal das wohl
mein talent gesehen hast das ist schon
mal gut
du kannst du in zukunft natürlich mein
album und sowieso nicht erst mal
abschicken
danach strebe ich natur an der
wahrscheinlich eine solo tür zu tür
solotour und mal gucken da werden auch
damit auf jeden fall noch einiges kommen
ich hoffe du bleibst dran auf meine
seite facebook ist das habe ich immer
auf jeden fall also die ganzen stadt
bekannt geben ich werde auf jeden fall
eine menge machen heute sensationell war
mal wieder eine rote nennen um sie
aggressiv noch ich werde nicht aggressiv
ich bin ja der krachten alt gerade das
wohl der zeitgenossen ist hier ja gar
nicht erst auf radikale heute hin oder
her einmal kriminell immer kriminell
ja das hat er wirklich gefragt ja du
hast recht vorgeschrieben ist ich habe
ja schließlich sein aber es ist auf
jeden fall hier ich kann jederzeit ich
will aber ich halte mich auf jeden fall
ich kämpfe dagegen an der große dschihad
mir da kann man sich selbst kämpfen
das nicht zu machen und solltet ihr auch
nicht mehr
sehr gut wieder eine rote oder grüne
jetzt noch eine grüne und zum schluss
eine rote damit wir auch die spannung
haben die ordnung stand wie schaffst du
es dass deine freunde so treu zu dir
stehen indem ich einfach zumal freundin
die wirklich freunde sind korrekt nennt
man musst du dein freund ehrlich sein
man muss viele sachen berücksichtigen
zum beispiel ein freund nicht [ __ ] für
eine frau verstehst du zu sagen würdest
du nie machen wenn du deine freundin
abdi ist am katschberg quasi unantastbar
nehme also von freunden die frau
anpacken machen auf jeden fall großes
tabu alter allawi an lügen immer ehrlich
sein größe nicht nicht für kleinigkeiten
freundschaft aufs spiel setzen
bei uns unsere freundeskreis wird das
auch freundschaften brüderschaft
natürlich sehr groß geschrieben und so
korrekt so also zu dem typ der das
geschrieben hat uns gefragt hat mit
unserer korrekter du bist du deinem
richtigen freunden genauso korrekt auch
zu dir sein
also man muss neuer seien einfach dann
ist das alles sehr gut sagte schluss
noch der letzte aufreger
wäre es nicht interessanter fan von
einem erfolgreichen fußball verein zu
sein keine frage
ich weiß auch eine scheiß frage weil fan
von fußball verein bin ich und wenn du
lieber fern von einem fußball vor allem
bist wenn du das so meint es statt von
mir entfernt zu sein ich überhaupt nicht
du kannst aber du kannst ja auch
trotzdem fragen gar nicht erst so verlas
anderem vfl bis zur fan von
was einmal verein oder bei allgemein
fußballfan ob es jetzt doch mit ist oder
weil du bist ja auch nicht meine idee
war es ja quasi fast profi ich war
selber fast profis wie du schon sagst
und fußball ist auf jeden fall etwas was
auf jeden fall von meinem herzen ist
wer sich in seiner fan von einem
erfolgreichen fußball zu sagen als
selber unerfolgreich pazifik das ist
wahrscheinlich das wäre mal eine frage
ja okay sie gemeinsam sicher gemeinden
wiederholt
also wäre es nicht interessanter fan von
einem erfolgreichen fußball zu sein als
selbst erfolglos fußball zu spielen
nein warum was hattest denn das eine mit
dem anderen zu tun sei wenn du erfolglos
fußballspiel du spielst fußball für dich
was du bist fit bleiben und kannst du
nach hause geht von einem
lieblingsmannschaft vor einem
lieblingsklub als anschauen also
anfeuern
doch weil es cool alte okay du kannst du
noch eine mixed auf dem platz ich spiele
ich habe jetzt letzter natürlich nicht
mehr so gespielten ist auch lange so ein
zwei jahren nicht mehr so spielt aber
schon ein bisschen zugenommen als die
band besteht alter aber sag ich ganz
ehrlich
fußballerisch gibt mir zwei wochen
training zwei wochen drei wochen ein
bisschen abnehmen schwöre euch kein
deutscher rapper und auch einige erst
bundesligisten und zweitens ließen
können auf jeden fall nicht mit mir
mithalten dann würde ich mal sagen afx
ist der beste fußballspieler unter den
deutschen opfern
die flat tax der wahrscheinlich war
definitiv mit auch mit deutscher
fußballer rapper von den rappern das
wasser reichen können also es ist zeit
für einen rapper fußballturnier oder
einen rock fußballturnier wäre es auf
jeden fall alle zeit auf jeweils
organisiert das ja okay und wir machen
noch gut also in meinem stand für die
großen respekt dem besten spieler